hey we're gonna go without technology
for an entire week everything that makes
us function in human beings it'll be
what I want to be like in the nineteen
hundreds ya know I'm dr. Cara baguette
and an adult and child and adolescent
psychiatrist I'm an assistant professor
as well as medical director of the
addiction Institute at Mount Sinai and
Center on addiction Alliance technology
uses sort of increased over time
especially during this time during the
pandemic we're all sort of indoors
people are highly connected to screens
we know that increasing technology use
is associated with depression anxiety
irritability and that's just in normal
use we can see increases in sort of
mental health symptoms with excessive
use as well as sort of withdrawal so
kudos to them for taking this challenge
during probably the most difficult time
to do it but there are still things to
do so ladies good luck to you both I
hope you have a very enjoyable five days
and we'll see you on the other end the
day one I think it's been calling okay
obviously Joyce and I vibe yeah pretty
Cardinal busted out
I feel like I'm gonna forget this in the
morning only because we have to wake up
and do a big activity and definitely
feelin liddie liddie like a brown titty
screen exposure leads to sort of release
of the same like chemicals the same
neurotransmitters in the brain that we
see with drugs some of the same when we
think about what's important and reward
we think about dopamine so we do expect
to see some of this sort of brain
related effects so after last night
we're getting to Liddy what still
influence it still employees don't get
the shot yeah so we're just gonna use
the spoiler camera and then after that
we're gonna go try to get it developed
yeah being able to immediately speed to
get them to bell hooks so if you got the
map
No where we had a wonder around and that
was difficult but it was fun if I didn't
have Joyce there with me I think I would
have gone crazy so we just got back from
the CVS we did good you know I think was
a great bonding experience for us you
know so day one maybe a little bit of a
novelty I believe day two and day three
will be the most difficult for these
ladies I have been bored all day facing
rough I need to check my phone what if
my mom called me we hit some bumps
yesterday we did a great job and now I'm
just gonna go pick up my what are you
doing
[Music]
choice messed up I messed up what is
this Oh getting hard I just gotta get
this like out of me you know so we're
gonna try and meditate
[Music]
when we're supposed to be socially
isolating and now layered on top of that
a lot of cities have curfews so you
can't get out quite as much but there's
still things to do they can read
magazines again in in paper newspapers
come in paper print edition so there
there are lots of things that they they
can engage and we had a successful day
together Joyce and I cooked together a
little bit and that was entertaining
personal as we don't spend a lot of time
in the kitchen we're gonna bake the
brownies
[Music]
beautiful amazing thing um we did get
two divots in it taking it out but they
look beautiful I don't know I'm kind of
enjoying this and physical activity go
for a run outside go for a walk a hike
so lots of really wonderful things to be
done even given the restrictions that we
that we are now sort of living under so
today I think it went wrong we decided
to go to the park and luckily I didn't
know how to get to the park so we didn't
have to go like oh crap we don't have
Google Maps out there that down takes a
little bit had a little bit of more of a
reading set and
you know we've jammed them problem I get
to hurt because I've never done that was
very fun actually actually really
enjoyed it until the ant starts thanks
for all in are correct that really
sucked I think honestly this whole
experience definitely we had our rocky
moment what I do this again no I think
it really took connects me to my soul I
don't know knees been all day with this
[Music]